la última disputa por la montaña se
libra hoy en la etapa 18 del tour de
francia un recorrido de 130 kilómetros
entre la ciudad de puno donde me
encuentro y la estación de deportes de
invierno
luz ardiden será un recorrido que se
completará a mitad de camino con dos
grandes de los pirineos precisamente el
paso de tomate y la propia meta de luz
ardiden será por supuesto una batalla
decisiva para los escaladores aunque es
poco probable que se produzcan cambios
en la clasificación general más allá de
los cinco primeros lugares y como
colofón de esta jornada el propio
presidente emmanuel macrón estará en la
meta para premiar a los ganadores